hi und herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid
Chat GPT ist eine Text KI über die
derzeit irgendwie alle sprechen das ist
eine Software das Unternehmens open ai
und die ist derzeit noch kostenlos das
heißt jeder von euch kann sich derzeit
so ein Account da erstellen und dann
dieser künstlichen Intelligenz im
Prinzip jede x-beliebige Frage stellen
und in wenigen Sekunden kriegt man dann
eine Antwort total egal zu welchem Thema
und das haben mittlerweile auch Schüler
Schülerinnen Lehrer und Lehrerin
mitbekommen jetzt werden die Schüler nie
wieder Hausaufgaben mehr machen
vielleicht habt ihr schon von der
künstlichen Intelligenz Chat gehört
diese künstliche Intelligenz ist so
krass dass sie einfach eure Hausaufgaben
machen kann sagen du kannst das
Hausaufgabe eine Geschichte zu schreiben
in der es um eine Spinne geht die ein
König ist gibt das Fetti BT als Auftrag
und guck was passiert schaut euch das an
diese ai schreibt einfach eine gesamte
Geschichte und die ist auch nicht mal
schlecht sondern die richtig sick ja das
ist einfach ein Game changer
ja und ein gamechanger ist das auch in
der akademischen Lehre ich weiß nicht ob
euch ob das jemand von euch kennt man
sitzt abends vorm PC und denkt sich boah
jetzt muss ich noch eine 5000
Zeichen Hausarbeit schreiben ich wünsche
die würde jemand für mich schreiben und
das ist gar nicht mehr so
realitätsfernsehen
und mit original die prüfen wir noch mal
dass der Content nicht plagiiert oder
eher generated ist um die
Zitierfähigkeit von Chat GPT zu prüfen
habe ich das wohl noch mal gefragt einen
kurzaufsatz zu schreiben über die
neuesten wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse
ob icos Rauchen schädlich ist und mir
auch die Quellen für die Studien zu
nennen die dem Aufsatz zugrunde liegen
wen überrascht ist die hat natürlich den
Aufsatz und die Quellen ausgespuckt und
jetzt beginnt das wissenschaftliche
Arbeiten denn ich brauche meine Quellen
in der chicago-salbeweise und die so
hold my Bier und so bitte Phase 3
weitere Studien zusammen und schreibe
die Quellen in der apaise unter die Bier
das Fazit wie man sieht ist Obst im Haus
und welch eine Überraschung Kinder als
icos ist fertig
ja ich habe mit Chat GPT auch schon so
ein bisschen rumgespielt und mir alles
mögliche erstellen lassen zum Beispiel
eine Hautpflege Routine ein Sportplan
oder verschiedene Rezepte und natürlich
die Anmoderation für diese ZDF heute
live Sendung und wie das funktioniert
hat das zeige ich euch einfach mal
schnell auf meinem PC ich habe da oben
also quasi in dieses Programm
geschrieben schreibt mir eine
Anmoderation für die Youtube Sendung ZDF
heute live in der es darum geht wie Chat
GPT unser Leben verändern wird und dann
ähm hat das Programm das gemacht dann
musste ich mir das Ganze allerdings noch
mal auf Deutsch übersetzen lassen und
dabei ist dann rausgekommen willkommen
bei ZDF heute live heute tauchen wir in
die Welt der KI ein und erfahren wie Sie
unser tägliches Leben verändert wir
werden die aufregenden Fortschritte in
der Technologie erkunden und wie Chat
GPT eine wichtige Rolle in dieser
Revolution spielt ob es unser Leben
einfacher macht oder die Art wie wir mit
Technologie interagieren verändert Chat
GPT prägt unsere Zukunft setzen Sie sich
zurück und begleiten Sie uns während wir
entdecken wie diese fortschrittliche KI
unsere Welt verändert ja klingt noch so
ein bisschen holprig an manchen Stellen
finde ich trotzdem ist es wahnsinnig
beeindruckend und wie diese Software
unser Bildungssystem unsere Arbeit und
auch unsere Freizeit verändert darüber
sprechen wir heute gemeinsam mit Euch
und mit bildungsunternehmer und matte
Youtuber Daniel jung und dr Tina
klüversies Unternehmen Unternehmerinnen
und ki-visionären und natürlich will ich
wie immer auch mit euch über dieses
Thema sprechen habt ihr schon
Erfahrungswerte was sind eure Fragen an
die beiden ExpertInnen zum Thema dann
schreibt sie uns gerne hier direkt in
den Youtube Chat oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zedf.de und jetzt begrüße ich
hier bei mir aber erstmal den Mann den
vielleicht einige von euch schon aus
seinen berühmten Mathe Videos kennen
vielleicht hat er euch schon mal durch
die ein oder andere Prüfung gebracht
hallo Daniel
hi schönen guten Abend schön dass du bei
uns bist Daniel erzähl uns mal wann hast
du denn diese Software das erste Mal
benutzt und was waren so deine ersten
Gedanken dazu
direkt als sie raus kam natürlich sofort
reingesprochen erste Gedanken warum hat
so lange gedauert dass es so viele jetzt
mitbekommen haben
die Technologie ist ja schon ein
bisschen länger parat ich habe vor
Jahren auch schon mein Video gemacht
sowohl vom Alpha das hat schon vor
Jahren die die Mathe Hausaufgaben
eigentlich gemacht hat so keine
interessiert und jetzt hat mich
interessiert warum hat das jetzt auf
einmal so ein Hype und ähm ja für mich
war es jetzt nicht so beeindruckend für
mich ist er jetzt beeindruckend was das
für eine Welle macht
für die die gerade zuschauen in die
vielleicht von dieser
aufmerksamkeitswelle mitbekommen haben
das Programm aber noch gar nicht selber
ausprobiert haben lasst uns noch mal
einen Blick darauf werfen was dieses
Programm alles kann das haben Sven
waskönig und Uta Ehlers für uns
zusammengefasst
bislang ist Jet GPT vor allem bei
Schülern und Studierenden beliebt
Hausaufgaben Aufsätze referate der
Chatbot kann all das Übernehmen durch
einen sogenanntes künstliches neuronales
Netzwerk das sich Informationen etwa aus
dem Internet sieht
ist größtenteils das was sie daraus
machen wenn Sie ein Autor sind dann
hilft es Ihnen beim Schreiben wenn Sie
eine Excel-Tabelle anlegen wollen dann
hilft es ihm ein Anliegen an der
Excel-Tabelle trainiert wurde das
Programm mit einer unfassbar großen
Datenmenge über 175 Milliarden Parameter
verfügt der Chatbot
ki-professor Christian Kersting an der
TU Darmstadt weiß wie aufwändig das
Training ist und mit welchen Daten
setzen Sie weiterlernt was jetzt Open
Air gemacht hat ist es hat sich Daten
genommen generiert ganz speziell danach
gefragt bei Menschen du sag mal wenn das
der Anfangstext ist und ich generiere
jetzt diese Daten diese nächsten Wörter
ich schreibe das sofort
klingt das gut ich finde deswegen Chat
GPT so toll weil falls da diesen
Quantensprung zumindest aus der Sicht
der KI-Forschung gegeben hat und wir
sind aber noch nicht beim Menschen die
entscheidende Technologie heißt deep
learning tiefes lernen eine Methode des
maschinellen selbstverbesserns bei der
komplexe Muster in großen Datenmengen
automatisch erkannt werden und so können
Rechner auch menschliche Kreativität
lernen
ja wir sehen es geht immer ganz viel um
Textverarbeitung um das Arbeiten mit
Texten du bist ja eigentlich total
bekannt als jemand der Menschen vor
allem mit mathematischen Fragestellungen
weiterhilft verändert die auch in diesem
Bereich was
ich glaube Chat gbt verändert einfach
jetzt alles weil es so eine
Aufmerksamkeit hat und ich sag ja allen
immer beschäftigt euch damit spielt
damit um testet es schaut dass das für
Möglichkeiten sind aber Chat GPT ist
sagen wir mal so der Mediane Abend von
dem was eigentlich im Bereich künstliche
Intelligenz also mal die letzten 18
Monate passiert ist und ich finde es
super spannend ich habe schon vor ein
paar Jahren ein Video gemacht Mathematik
beim neuronalen Netz und noch mal
irgendwie gefühlt bis zum die hat jetzt
nichts passiert wichtig ist jetzt
wirklich damit zu interagieren und das
jetzt nicht irgendwie zu verbieten
sondern zu schauen was ist möglich und
es hat auch Grenzen und man sollte vor
allen Dingen auch mal herausfinden was
kann eben nicht
ja Thema ausprobieren du bist ja in
engem Austausch mit einer riesen
Community bei der es immer viel darum
geht Dinge zu lernen Klausuren zu
bestehen wie sind denn da bisher so die
Rückmeldung aus der Community kriegst du
viele Fragen dazu also was sind gerade
so Kontaktpunkte die Schüler
Schülerinnen Studentin in deinen Augen
damit haben ja es war wie im Einspieler
hatte die ja auch
tiktok Videos dieser virale Effekt jetzt
gerade auf einmal schreiben
Hausaufgaben machen das macht eine Kurve
Diskussion das macht vollkommen Alpha
schon seit zehn Jahren
also die Rückmeldung ist ganz klar man
sieht jetzt eine Möglichkeit dass die
Hausaufgaben mal eben so gemacht werden
das ist eigentlich so die Gefahr jetzt
eigentlich der Auftrag von uns
eigentlich im Bildungssystem dass wir
proaktiv damit umgehen wir sollten jetzt
eben schauen wie stellen wir jetzt
eigentlich die Lehre der Zukunft die
Bildung der Zukunft auf
ja passend dazu haben wir schon eine
Frage aus der Community an dich und zwar
vom YouTube User Miata for Life der oder
die fragt sollte man seiner Meinung nach
also deiner Meinung nach das Programm
den Schülern als Unterstützung an die
Hand geben oder sollte man es in der
Schule versuchen geheim zu halten ich
weiß nicht wie gut das jetzt noch
funktionieren sollte das Thema geheim
halten ist vorbei und es sollte jetzt
eigentlich unter Aufsicht und wenn jetzt
Lehrkräfte sagen soll ich machen oder
nicht wir haben auch in Deutschland ganz
viele Experten ich habe noch von Tine
Forschungsstudien in dem Bereich
gestartet man künstliche Intelligenz ist
ja schon lange in unserem Alltag mit
dabei und jetzt haben auch wir die
Möglichkeit geben damit etwas zu machen
und ihr dürft auf keinen Fall uns dem
verwehren sondern müssen damit jetzt
lernen umzugehen und ihm zu schauen wie
kann es uns auch helfen das haben wir
auch von einem Einspieler gemerkt was
kann wie kein Auto davon profitieren wie
hast du davon profitiert für die
Anmoderation es sondern miteinander sein
Mensch und Maschine
ja sagen immer Schule Bildungssystem
Universitäten sind vielleicht nicht
unbedingt der Bereich in Deutschland der
als besonders technologieoffen
wahrgenommen wurde so in den letzten
Jahren im letzten Jahrzehnt was ist denn
deine Erfahrung wie reagiert denn diese
Seite des
Bildungssystems auf diese Technik ja es
ist so gefühlte Panik gerade so aber zu
Recht also was sagen Prüfung jetzt noch
aus was sollten wir eigentlich
überprüfen wie überprüfen wir eigentlich
vermittelte Kompetenzen ich habe heute
noch mit einem Professor der in der
Forschungsschule dabei ist gesprochen er
sagte und wenn man jetzt damit cheaten
also betrügen kann ja lass sie betrügen
und findet heraus wie und dann lass uns
doch gemeinsam jetzt überlegen wie
können wir in die Zukunft gehen und noch
mal die leere neue aufstellen und wir
dürfen uns jetzt um Gottes Willen nicht
dem verwehren ich habe so ein bisschen
so ein bisschen diese Ruhe 2011 über
Video lernen gesprochen habe verfilmt
doch alle eure vorliegen und stellt die
doch Additiv und zu damit zu testen
bereit und gemeinsam irgendwie überlegen
was können Erklärvideos und jetzt haben
wir aber durch den Speed der da draußen
herrscht keine Zeit mehr irgendwie zehn
Jahre zu warten sondern müssen das jetzt
aufnehmen wir müssen testen und das
gemeinsam und wir müssen vor allen
Dingen mutig sein uns dem anzunehmen
jetzt haben wir ja gerade in diesem
tiktok Clip schon gesehen dass da jemand
gesagt hat diese Technologie ermöglicht
es euch sämtliche Hausaufgaben zu lösen
das ist natürlich irgendwie blöd weil
dafür ist Schule ja nicht da ich frage
mich jetzt mach diese Technologie wenn
sie nicht richtig angewendet wird
eigentlich das Lernen dann absolet also
werden wir letztendlich durch diese
Technologie alle auch ein Stück dümmer
ähm jetzt lustigerweise haben wir auch
Wissenschaft in der Studie mit dabei das
ist dieses Phänomen ich kann doch alles
Google das war ja voll ich kann alles
googeln aber so geht ja nicht sich
Wissen aneignen was passiert da oben
worauf beruht eigentlich die blonding
neuronale Netze das ist ja eigentlich
total spannend in welche Zukunft gehen
wir ähm ich sage ganz einfach wir müssen
das jetzt einfach mit aufnehmen wir
müssen uns damit beschäftigen und wir
müssen einfach natürlich darüber
nachdenken was müssen wir noch können
ähm was brauchen wir für eine Basis aber
es ist jetzt ähm nicht so dass wir
einfach sagen ja wir können jetzt alles
gucken jetzt können wir alles chat gptin
oder was auch immer in der Zukunft
sondern was machen wir mit den Chat gpts
dieser Welt und wie bereiten wir
natürlich auch unseren Nachwuchs auf die
Zukunft vor denn die Arbeit Zukunft und
das ist jetzt eingeläutet final mit
Jetski
ist anders als bisher und da heißt es
jetzt wir müssen uns dem Annehmen wir
müssen damit um experimentieren schauen
was geht aber eben auch was nicht geht
denn aus dem einen Spieler wir müssen
eben auch vorsichtig sein
hat auch viel Falsches ausgespielt umso
wichtiger ist es jetzt anstatt dass
irgendeiner jetzt die Hausaufgaben
machen lässt es gibt was falsches ab ähm
also da sind auch viele eben viele
Gefahren und das geht einfach nur da
gibt's gemeinsam rangehen und das bitte
auch kuratiert mit Experten
ich habe gerade mal so einen kleinen
Blick in die Kommentare geworfen die
Stimmung bei euch da draußen ist auf
jeden Fall sehr gemischt Jan door
schreibt zum Beispiel auf Facebook
beeindruckend schon für viele
Kleinigkeiten verwendet auch um beim
Programmieren zu helfen Francis Lee
Sternberg schreibt auf Facebook ich
finde den Chatbot gruselig vor allem
wenn man erkennt wie selektiv
beziehungsweise gefärbt er auf bestimmte
Themen die Antworten gibt Daniel noch
eine letzte Frage erstmal an Dich der
YouTube User mega Miki full fragt wie
lange könnte es denn dauern bis Chat GPT
in wirklich großen Skalen nutzbar ist
muss man wahrscheinlich Microsoft jetzt
fragen die sind da wahrscheinlich am
tiefsten gerade drin durch das nächste
Invest die Frage kannst du nicht
beantworten du musst dich einfach mit
dem was beschäftigen was dort passiert
ich empfehle zum Beispiel immer Andrew
in
der hat coustera mit gegründet hat die
ki-abteilung von Google geleitet wir
hatten super Ted Vortrag der dort
erklärt was da gerade passiert und noch
mal Chat open hat ja noch ganz viele
andere Anwendungsmöglichkeiten das ist
erst gerade der Beginn und wann die
nächste Version Lounge wann der Zugriff
zum Internet wirklich da ist auch Google
ist da dran Meter ist da dran
dieses Jahr wird viel passieren und ich
empfehle nicht damit zu beschäftigen
aber wirklich auch eine tiefe damit zu
beschäftigen was heißt das eigentlich
was ist günstig Intelligenz welche
Fortschritte gab es und die spannend
kann es eigentlich sein dass jetzt in
den in den Alltag zu integrieren
ja danke Daniel erstmal bis hierhin wir
kriegen auf jeden Fall super viele
Fragen an dich an alle deren Frage jetzt
noch nicht beantwortet beantwortet wurde
hier noch mal der Hinweis Daniel und ich
gehen gleich so ca um 20:15 Uhr auch
noch mal gemeinsam live auf dem insta
Kanal von ZDF heute also wenn eure Frage
ist nicht gestellt wurde stellt die
gerne gleich noch mal bei Instagram
Daniel wir sehen uns gleich vielen Dank
erstmal bis hierhin
ja und jetzt wollen wir vom Thema
Bildung noch mal so ein bisschen auf das
größere Bild schauen äh Chat GPT
verändert ja nicht nur das Thema Bildung
sondern auch in ganz vielen anderen
Lebensbereichen einiges und dazu
sprechen wir mit Dr Tina Klüver sie ist
Unternehmerin und KI Visionärin hallo
Frau Klüver schön dass Sie bei uns sind
hallo freut mich auch vielen Dank ja und
wenn ihr Fragen an Frau Krüger habt
schickt die gerne in den Chat oder per
Mail jetzt frage ich Frau Klüver einfach
auch noch mal was war denn für sie der
erste Moment in dem Sieger GP benutzt
haben und wie haben sie reagiert
tatsächlich war der erste Moment auch
ich denke Ende letzten Jahres als ich
dann auch dachte gut als jemand der sich
sehr sehr lange mit Chatbots beschäftigt
habe der lange geforscht zum Thema
Chatbots und auch zum Thema
Sprachverstehen von Maschinen muss ich
erstmal selber aussuchen das hat deine
Zeit lang gedauert bis ich tatsächlich
Zugang bekommen habe das war ja auch
damals schon sehr überlaufen aber als
ich dann ausprobieren konnte habe ich
tatsächlich versucht mit dem System zu
chatten und da war ich sehr erstaunt
dass das ja tatsächlich nicht ging also
ich verstehe jetzt unter chatten
tatsächlich sowas wie wir jetzt
miteinander machen wir sprechen
miteinander wir haben unsere
individuellen Meinungen wir haben
vielleicht auch eine Persönlichkeit und
ein Chatbot ist ja auch immer bis jetzt
auch häufig so interpretiert und
definiert worden dass er eben diese Art
von Eigenauskunft auch bringt und da war
ich sehr überrascht dass tatsächlich ja
definitiv diese Art von Kommunikation
und verbindet
ich denke das ist sehr geschickt weil
gerade diese Art von Kommunikation ja
auch eben diese Bewusstsein die Schiene
Maschine mit Bewusstsein diese
Diskussion auch immer sehr stark
kriegert deshalb war das sehr geschickt
von Open aber wir haben ja das erste Mal
tatsächlich eine Maschine die nicht wie
vorher immer sagt ich kann sie nicht
verstehen ich kann sie nicht verstehen
weil sie es tatsächlich nicht kann
sondern wir haben ja eine Maschine die
sagt ich kann mich dazu nicht äußern
obwohl sie es könnte und das war schon
sehr beeindruckend
ja so Thema Trigger oder vielleicht auch
ja einfach verbunden mit dem Thema
künstliche Intelligenz da kommen
bestimmt auch bei vielen so eine Art ja
so so
Ängste hoch dass man denkt boah krass
jetzt kann diese KI schon so viel wie
soll das denn in 15 Jahren sein könnte
so eine KI vielleicht auch gerade im
Text verarbeitenden Bereich auch meinen
Job ersetzen
ja da gibt's natürlich viele Bedenken
das verstehe ich auch gut wir haben eben
schon gesehen oder auch gehört im bei
Herrn jungen das ja viele Fakten das
Systems immer noch nicht sicher gewusst
werden das ist ja auch verständlich das
System lernt aus großen Mengen von Daten
und diese Daten können ja ich mache mal
ganz einfaches Beispiel die können auch
veraltet sein unsere Welt entwickelt
sich ja massiv schnell jeden Tag weiter
Dinge verändern sich wir haben auch eine
sehr antike Welt wir haben
Personen die gleich heißen wir haben
Veranstaltungen die gleich heißen wir
haben
Dinge die nicht direkt auflösbar sind
und das macht so ein System natürlich
Schwierigkeiten und dadurch kann es
natürlich passieren dass die Sachen
Informationen liefert eben nicht 100%
verlässlich sind und das ist ein Fakt
den wir auf jeden Fall noch haben und
wenn wir an eine Situation kommen wollen
wir verlassen uns wirklich 100%ig auf
die Maschine so dass wir eigentlich
einen menschlichen Mitarbeiter gar nicht
mehr benötigen dann müssen wir dieses
Unternehmen auf jeden Fall vorher in den
Griff bekommen und das ist aktuell noch
Forschungsgegenstand tatsächlich also
das kann ich nicht sagen dass wir da
jetzt nächstes Jahr schon wären weil die
Kombination von Fakten wissen und diesen
dialogischen Wissen aus der
sprachmaschine ist noch nicht gelöst
deshalb würde ich sagen wir haben hier
auf keinen Fall schon ein System obwohl
man sich Sorgen machen sollte sondern es
ist ein Werkzeug das ist ein Werkzeug
das genutzt werden kann um textuelle
Arbeiten zu unterstützen wenn ich also
beispielsweise bei meinem Beruf einen
Text schreiben ich muss selber auch
viele Texte schreiben dann ist das ein
gutes Werkzeug dass ich nutzen kann das
ist ja auch nicht jedem in die Wiege
gelegt gute Texte zu schreiben trotzdem
wird es häufig vorausgesetzt und da kann
natürlich so eine Maschine als Werkzeug
einfach sehr gut weiterhelfen ich sage
ich möchte das auch noch mal aufgreifen
dass wir eben auch schon gehört haben
bezüglich der Hausarbeiten
beispielsweise oder an der Schule und da
frage ich mich tatsächlich wenn wir ein
Werkzeug erfinden was in der Lage ist
für uns so wunderbare Tex zu schreiben
auch wenn wir die natürlich noch mal
kontrollieren müssen und auch gucken
müssen ob die auf unsere
Qualitätsansprüche passen und dann
zwingen wir aber die Leute dieses Tool
nicht zu benutzen das kommt mir ein
bisschen so vor als würden wir
Taucheranzug finden und die Leute dann
weiterhin zwingen die Luft anzuhalten
obwohl wir sehr viel Möglichkeiten
hätten mit diesem Tauchanzug auch in sag
mal tiefe Wasser zu tauchen und dort
interessante Entdeckungen zu machen
ja Entdeckung und aber auch das Thema
falsche Information und dazu haben wir
auch eine Meinung aus der Community die
ist ganz passend dazu vom User Copy
Paste nicht befürchte es wird eine große
Herausforderung wenn nicht sogar
unmöglich sein Meinungsmache durch
natürlich klingende und gut
ausformulierte aber eben durch KI
generierte Kommentare zu filtern in
einigen Monaten wird man nicht mehr
zwischen bot und Mensch unterscheiden
können solange man nicht eine extrem
sichere Methode findet die Echtheit von
Menschen anonym zu verifizieren also
hier die Angst vor quasi einer Fake News
Welle
ja ich denke Fake News ist ein Thema
dass wir ja auch jetzt schon sehen ganz
ohne diese Maschinen und ich denke wir
müssen uns als Gesellschaft auf jeden
Fall mit diesem Phänomen der
Falschinformationen viel viel stärker
noch auseinandersetzen das hat sich in
den letzten Jahren hat sich auch in der
probe-pandemie noch mal deutlich gezeigt
ich denke es hat jetzt wirklich jeder
verstanden dass das wichtig ist dass
Wissenschaftskommunikation wichtig ist
dass es wichtig ist eben auch die
Kommunikation die im Internet
stattfindet auch zu ja zum Monitoren und
ich glaube das Problem ist eher ein
gesellschaftliches als jetzt dieses
dieser Maschine weil wir haben das
genauso jetzt auch schon und wir müssen
uns damit auf jeden Fall
auseinandersetzen und dann lösen dafür
für unsere Gesellschaft finden und das
sehe ich eigentlich unabhängig davon
dass wir diese Maschinen einsetzen
Umfeld nicht zu schreiben weil wenn wir
ganz ganz viele Menschen einsetzen zu
schreiben dann haben wir eigentlich den
gleichen Effekt
ja ich denke es wird ganz gut deutlich
aus unserem Gespräch jetzt aber auch aus
dem Gespräch von mit Daniel das ist auf
jeden Fall eine Technologie ist die
unser aller Leben betrifft deswegen ist
es ja auch spannend mal darauf zu gucken
wem gehört diese Technik eigentlich
aktuell und wer zeigt aktuell ein großes
Interesse daran das hat sich Christian
Volk für uns angeguckt
hinter Chat GPT steckt das Unternehmen
open ai aus Kalifornien 2015 gestartet
als Forschungslabor für künstliche
Intelligenz und mit einer Milliarde
US-Dollar Kapital unter anderem von
Prominenten Geldgebern wie tesla-chef
Elon Musk damals ist Open ai eine
gemeinnützige Organisation will Produkte
für alle und nicht nur für Aktionäre
schaffen vier Jahre später ist damit
erstmal Schluss das Unternehmen gibt den
Status wieder auf um besser an Kapital
zu kommen kurz darauf zahlt Microsoft
eine Milliarde Dollar für die exklusive
Nutzung der Technologie nun will der
technik-krise die Produkte weiter
ausbauen laut US-Medien mit 10
Milliarden Dollar der Plan dahinter die
künstliche Intelligenz könnte in die
Suchmaschine bringen oder Programme wie
Word oder Outlook integriert werden
ja wir haben es gerade gehört Microsoft
zahlt enorme Summen für die exklusive
Nutzung dieser Technik und da kommt
natürlich so ein bisschen die Frage auch
ist das nicht auch problematisch wenn so
eine Welt verändernde Technik dann
wieder in die Hände von
privatwirtschaftlichen Unternehmen Gerät
tatsächlich war open ja ursprünglich
auch gestartet als Open Source Lösung
und es gibt sehr sehr viele Menschen die
das natürlich bedauern dass das jetzt
anders gekommen ist und Microsoft sich
die Rechte daran gesichert es ist
natürlich auch zu bedenken dass nicht
nur Microsoft an solchen Technologien
dann forscht und auch diese
weiterentwickelt sondern das eigentlich
die großen Technologie Firmen alle an
diesen Technologien auch weiter forschen
es gibt einen System bei Google was er
ähnliche Funktionalität hat es gibt auch
ähm bei chinesischen Anbietern ähnliche
Funktionalität und es gibt sogar auch in
Europa
Initiativen die eben ein europäisches
großes Netzwerk wie dieses ähm schaffen
wollen und dafür denke ich auch sollte
man sich unbedingt einsetzen denn es ist
eine Form von Abhängigkeit wenn wir nur
auf sowohl was den Wettbewerbsvorteil
betrifft als auch dass die ich sag mal
die Daten und Werte betrifft die in so
einem System gespeichert sind wenn wir
uns da komplett auf die USA oder aus
China stützen müssen und daher
unterstütze ich sehr die die deutschen
und auch europäischen Initiativen es
gibt verschiedene Unternehmen die
tatsächlich ich sag mal diesen Kampf
gegen die Großen aufnehmen aber es gibt
auch Open Source Initiativen
beispielsweise in Frankreich und in
Schweden die ähnlich große Netze bauen
und zur Verfügung stellen wollen
ja die USA und auch China also die
Marktführer was KI angeht das hat man ja
immer wieder ich habe jetzt eine Studie
gelesen zum KI Standort Deutschland die
sagt wir sind eigentlich schon ganz gut
darin Talente auszubilden aber die
wandern uns quasi nach der Ausbildung
dann ab wie steht es denn aus ihrer
Perspektive gerade um den ki-standort
Deutschland und was muss noch besser
funktionieren
ja das ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz ganz
sensibles Thema die Abwanderung der
sogenannte brain drain ist ein ein
großes ein ein großer Risiko für unseren
Standort hier
da gibt es leider immer noch in den USA
vor allen Dingen
Konditionen für Forschungsprojekte und
für Tätigkeiten in der Wirtschaft die
einfach so verlockend sind dass sich
viele dagegen auch einfach nicht so sehr
setzen wollen und ich glaube da müssen
wir auf jeden Fall schauen wie wir hier
unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und unsere
Standortvorteile auch nutzen können wir
haben Vorteile hier in Europa wir haben
eine hohe Lebensqualität wir haben auch
durchaus das ein oder andere
regulatorische Gesetz was vielen auf
gefällt das heißt das sollten wir
unbedingt aufbauen was wir allerdings
auch gucken müssen ist dass wir von der
wissenschaftlichen Erforschung von
verschiedenen neuen Technologien da sind
wir gar nicht schlecht auch in die
Umsetzung kommen und da haperts
tatsächlich noch ein kleines bisschen
wir haben immer wieder Phänomene in
denen neue Technologien in Europa
erforscht werden und erfunden werden
dann aber zum Beispiel in den USA
vermarktet werden und ich glaube da
können wir uns noch steigern das müssen
wir noch noch stärker kriegen dass wir
eben diese ganzen spannenden
Technologien auch in die Umsetzung
bekommen und dann haben wir aber auf
jeden Fall eine gute Chance hier auch
was zu bewegen was unseren Maßstäben
entspricht und das womit wir in dem
Wettbewerb gehen können
ja wir haben auf der einen Seite
irgendwie die Förderung dieser
Technologien auf der anderen Seite kam
eben auch das Thema Regularien auf und
jetzt sehen wir ja schon dass nur diese
technologie-chat GPT schon echt für
Chaos irgendwie an Schulen oder an
Universitäten sorgt bei keiner so
richtig weiß wie man jetzt damit umgehen
soll liegt das dann nicht auch beim
Start das stärker zu regulieren
der Staat hat natürlich immer den
Nachteil sage ich mal dass er hinterher
hängt hinter diesen Technologien die
sich ja sehr sehr schnell entwickeln wir
haben in der künstlichen Intelligenz in
den letzten drei Jahren unglaubliche
Entwicklung gesehen das ging wahnsinnig
schnell und sich dann politisch dazu zu
positionieren dauert natürlich seine
Zeit wir haben in Europa ein Gesetz für
die Regulierung von künstliche
Intelligenz das schon einiger Zeit jetzt
in der Mache ist und schon in der ersten
Fassung jetzt verabschiedet wurde wo
sich jetzt die Mitgliedstaaten noch so
äußern müssen
vieles an diesem Gesetz muss ich
persönlich aber auch sagen sich durchaus
auch kritisch denn kürzlich in die Jens
kann ja für viele verschiedene
Applikationen eingesetzt werden die
Anwendungsmöglichkeiten von künstlichen
die ganzen enorm groß und wenn wir
anfangen jetzt die Technologie an sich
zu limitieren in ihren Möglichkeiten
dann ist das auch etwas was uns wiederum
stoppt was verhindern kann und das wäre
sehr sehr schade und deshalb muss man
schon sehr genau hingucken aber auf der
anderen Seite haben wir natürlich auch
die erste ja europaweite Regulierung für
eben autonomesysteme überhaupt das ist
weltweit die einzige dieser Art
wir haben hier noch mal ein paar Stimmen
aus der Community und zwar sagt
Alexander Hahne auf Youtube ich glaube
der kommt auch aus dem Bildungsbereich
also ein ein Mann den direkt betrifft
ich experimentiere mit Chat GPT in der
Schule beim Erstellen von Theaterstück
Texten Monologen und Dialogen
funktioniert echt super die Kreativität
beim inszenieren kommt ja noch von den
Schülern und ähm passend dazu vielleicht
von Oliver W auf YouTube eine Frage an
Sie welche weiteren ki-anwendungen neben
Chatbots wird es geben Sie mir gerade
gesagt die Einsatzbereiche für KI sind
viel breiter eigentlich
ja dazu kann man auf jeden Fall sagen
was es definitiv geben wird oder auch
schon gibt ist ja könntest du dich
Intelligenz basierend auf anderen Daten
also hier sehen wir jetzt Text Beispiele
und auch schon da ist die
Anwendungsmöglichkeit natürlich immens
weil vieles was Menschen machen basiert
auf Sprache
darüber hinaus gibt es aber natürlich
auch diese großen Netze diese großen
ki-netze für Bilder und es gibt sie auch
für Videos und es wird sie geben für
Audio und es wird sie auch geben in der
Kombination von all diesen wobei Sprache
dann wieder der entscheidende Kleber
zwischen diesen verschiedenen Medien ist
das heißt wir werden Systeme haben haben
Sie schon jetzt in den ersten Anfängen
die multimodal sind das heißt die
verbinden Bilddaten beispielsweise mit
Textdaten mit Videodaten und können auch
darüber über diese ganzen verschiedenen
Arten von Daten
arbeiten und die können dann generieren
aus die verschiedenen modalen angeboten
und können darüber hinaus natürlich noch
mal ganz andere Dinge für Menschen zur
Verfügung stellen als es ein reines
textnetzwerk
ja wir haben es gerade gehört es gibt
Bilder es gibt Videos es gibt Grafiken
es gibt Sprache die generiert wird und
dazu fragt Andreas Marco Klusch auf
Facebook wie sehen Sie denn die Gefahr
von Plagiaten durch Tschech gbt das ist
ja auch was was oft diskutiert wird
gerade was ist mit Künstler
künstlerischem Schaffen und mit der
Kopie von solchen
ja ist auf jeden Fall Thema mit dem wir
uns noch mehr auseinandersetzen müssen
es gibt ja schon verschiedene
Bestrebungen dazu wie man das handhaben
könnte es gibt auch sehr
unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu das ist
ganz unbestritten es gibt das intensiv
ich sage mal der Skala 0 von wegen ist
dürfte eigentlich überhaupt nicht in
irgendeiner Form genutzt werden wenn ich
als Künstler beispielsweise meine Daten
ins Netz stelle dann ist es ähm auf
jeden Fall schon Plagiaten
kopfhörerverletzung wenn die Maschine
das liest und benutzt auf der anderen
Seite gibt es das dass die haben
komplette Gegenteil wo Menschen
Befürworter sagen das muss alles genutzt
werden dürfen und es ist etwas anderes
wenn eine Maschine das nutzt als wenn
jetzt ein Mensch sich da ein Plagiat
draus erstellt und ich denke wir müssen
da noch sehr ja noch etwas länger im
gesellschaftlichen Diskurs zu stehen
weil auch da gibt es Beispiele dafür in
der Vergangenheit in der wir auch
überreguliert haben denke ich wir
beispielsweise mal versucht mit einem
Gesetz die Möglichkeiten von Google in
zu limitieren indem wir gesagt haben
Google es darf das leistungsschutzgesetz
verbietet das Texte analysiert werden um
dann in so kleinen Zusammenfassungen von
zwei drei Sätzen eben diese zusammen
wieder wiederzugeben und genau das hat
aber Google in keinster Weise irritiert
dafür aber etliche andere kleinere
Startups und Geschäftsmodelle leider ja
nicht mehr fortführen lassen und deshalb
denke ich wir müssen da schon die Mitte
finden wir müssen schauen dass die
Künstler natürlich nicht um ihre
Leistungen geprellt werden und wir
müssen trotzdem auf der anderen Seite
auch sicherstellen dass wir eben den
Vorteil dieser Maschine nicht
umsonst verhindern
lassen Sie uns jetzt zum Schluss noch
mal so ein bisschen auf das Thema Arbeit
Arbeitswelt gucken hier schreibt jemand
auf Youtube und zwar Mathe short ich
denke künstliche Intelligenz wird eher
ein Werkzeug Werkzeug bzw Hilfe sein um
einfacher eine qualitativ bessere Arbeit
verrichten zu können nur sehr monotone
repetitive Jobs könnten ersetzt werden
und dazu sagt Gustav rein traurig dass
bei vielen Dingen das
Zwischenmenschliche nicht mehr
berücksichtigt wird z.B Bewerberauswahl
und Felix schirling fragt auf Youtube
dazu wie hilft den Chat GPT im
Berufsleben vielleicht können wir noch
mal gucken was kann zum Schluss jeder
der hier gerade zuschaut ganz konkret
für sich und sein oder ihr Arbeitsleben
mitnehmen
tatsächlich waren das jetzt natürlich
viele Anregungen verschiedene Aspekte
auch da drin
Shetty PPT ist in sprachbasiert das
System es geht um Text das kann Text
generieren das heißt jeder der in seiner
Arbeit damit konfrontiert ist Texte zu
generieren sei es beispielsweise ich sag
mal könnte sein dass jemand im Marketing
tätig ist es könnte sein dass jemand
journalistischen Bereich tätig ist es
könnte aber auch sein dass jemand
technische Dokumentation macht alle
diese Bereiche können von einer
textgenerierungsmaschine wie Check gpty
profitieren insofern als dass sie
beispielsweise die Angst vor dem leeren
Platz sag ich mal überkommen und
allererste Entwürfe mit der Maschine
schreiben lassen die dann noch mal
durchgehen kontrollieren ob die a von
den Fakten her passt aber B auch ob sie
vielleicht zu der Tonalität passt ob sie
zu meinen Qualitätsansprüchen passt ja
alle diese Dinge nochmal zu überprüfen
und dann eventuell anzupassen ich sehe
jetzt GPT da im Grunde eigentlich
ähnlich wie ein Werkzeug für Dolmetscher
und Übersetzer die ja auch bereits schon
mit machine translation also mit
maschineller Übersetzung arbeiten aber
alle diese Texte die dann generiert
werden von der Maschine natürlich noch
mal kontrollieren und auch noch mal
auf ihre Tonalität überprüfen und ich
denke das ist so eine Art und Weise wir
müssen uns einfach daran gewöhnen dass
wir Werkzeuge haben die auch unsere
Denkarbeit unterstützen und nicht nur
wie wir es bis jetzt gehabt haben schon
seit langer Zeit Werkzeuge die uns
beispielsweise in unserer Kraft
unterstützen oder in unserer
Geschwindigkeit Liebe wie ein Kran oder
ein Bagger der alle diese Dinge sind ja
für uns völlig selbstverständlich kein
Mensch würde mehr von jemand von einem
Bauarbeiter verlangen dass er alles von
alleine schleppt mit einer Körperkraft
ja dafür gibt's Maschinen die können das
machen und die können das auch besser
und die schon auf diesen Menschen der
das sonst alleine machen müsste und
genauso müssen wir uns das jetzt auch
vorstellen wir haben ja eine neue Klasse
von Werkzeugen die wir nutzen können um
unsere Denkarbeit zu unterstützen unsere
kognitiven arbeiten also genau die
meisten Büro
und da hat die Technik bei Frau klüvert
gerade leider kurz versagt ich konnte
auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge
mitnehmen und ich habe auf jeden Fall
noch einige spannende Fragen aber die
können wir auch gleich noch besprechen
ich gehe nämlich gleich mit Daniel jung
noch mal live auf dem insta Kanal von
ZDF heute und zum Schluss möchte ich
gerne noch mal einen Kommentar mit euch
teilen von Bennos project auf Youtube
der hat GPT gebeten einen Kommentar zu
schreiben und dieser Kommentar lautet
ich bin begeistert von ZDF tiefgründigem
Einblick in das Thema es ist erstaunlich
zu sehen wie weit Technologien bereits
fortgeschritten sind ja oh und ich höre
gerade Frau Klüver ist wieder da die
Technik hat uns doch nicht verlassen das
heißt ich werde Frau Klüver jetzt doch
noch mal ein paar von euren Fragen
stellen hallo Frau Klüver schön dass sie
zurück sind ja hallo Entschuldigung na
Thema Technik ne letztendlich
versagt es dann trotzdem manchmal aber
schön dass Sie wieder bei uns sind ich
finde zum Schluss noch mal ganz
interessant zu fragen und das findet
auch eine Userin sie haben es gerade
gesagt wir haben schon lange eigentlich
Unterstützung bei unserer körperlichen
Arbeit jetzt haben wir quasi auch eine
Stütze für unsere mentale Arbeit und
dazu fragt Anja Mattern auf Youtube was
macht das eigentlich mit der emotionalen
Intelligenz und mit der sozialen
Kompetenz gibt es dazu schon Forschung
tatsächlich Forschung ja also Forschung
die sich damit beschäftigt wie wir auch
mit Maschinen interagieren und was
Interaktion mit Maschinen und so eine
Computer gestützte Interaktion
untereinander mit uns macht das auf
jeden Fall forschungsseitig schon ja
wird viel dran gearbeitet aber
tatsächlich jetzt in irgendeiner Form
das in dieses Thema auch schon reingeht
ist es sehr wenig weil wir auch das
meinte ich ganz am Anfang
dazu entschieden eben die ganzen
menschlichen Fragen also sowas wie wie
geht es Dir was machst du heute ich war
gestern im Kino hat diesen Notfall
gesehen wie findest ähm also diese Dinge
werden ja sehr stark reguliert werden
limitiert man kann im Grunde mit die
kaum solche Gespräche führen
bewusst gewählt ja also dann weil genau
diese Art von Kommunikation mit der
Maschine mit uns Menschen etwas macht
was wir noch nicht hundertprozentig
verstehen und dass dadurch bis wir das
verstehen und bis wir wirklich sicher
sein können wie wir damit umgehen wollen
erstmal limitiert wird und Open Alter
ganz dezent die Entscheidung getroffen
hat das so im gewissen Grad zu
unterbinden
Frau Klüver jetzt sage ich aber danke
dass Sie so fleißig meine Fragen und die
Fragen der Community beantwortet haben
ich bin sehr gespannt was da noch kommt
und wir werden bestimmt noch mal zu dem
Thema sprechen vielen Dank
ganz herzlichen Dank auch
jetzt habe ich ja gerade schon
verfrühtes Schlusswort gehabt was denkt
ihr denn zu dem Thema habt ihr schon
ausprobiert wenn nicht probiert es doch
mal aus und schreibt uns vielleicht mal
einen KI generierten Kommentar hier
unter das Video und wenn ihr noch Lust
habt weiter zu diskutieren zum Thema KI
Chat GPT und Bildung mit mir und Daniel
jung dann geht jetzt gerne gleich mal in
so 10 Minuten auf den insta Kanal von
ZDF heute da gehen wir gleich noch mal
live ich bedanke mich aber ganz herzlich
erstmal für eure Kommentare und Fragen
zu dieser Sendung und freue mich wenn
ihr bald mal wieder einschaltet bei ZDF
heute live
[Musik]